[Music]
in lifehacks news submitted by flashing
lights here are 10 ways to make friends
easier waiting for another like a
[ __ ] I'm not even playing the
only person that gets excited for a
listicle
that's a bad bad millennial tell you
about listicles alright listicles have
wasted so much of my life but fulfilling
my mind but they fulfilled I'm so empty
after I always tricked by them yeah I'm
so empty ass like alcohol right it's a
depressant what kind of what kind
listicles are you looking at like five
ways to be productive unproductive
listicles girl you got a look at where
are they now ten celebrities that went
to [ __ ] cause you got one life we saw
Chris Kirkpatrick from NSYNC he was
cracking jokes at himself would you see
him no as a benefit concert ya benefit
thing before and he was singing with mr.
belding from Saved by the Bell yo mr.
building I want in sync collab it was
great that's dope I bet you they both
don't get [ __ ] oh yeah they get more
[ __ ] than I'll ever see in my life yeah
I'll never laugh at a hat you want to
I'm just talking about like in my
lifetime of your words kiss are these
all right number one yes number one
emphasize your similarities when you
meet someone you o go like for friends
or like a date or whatever just so many
people like you easily excuse me I
forgot what this if you like people into
liking you how to manipulate people in
girls do that a lot yeah I was just
gonna say that that was actually the
article title but I helped tip on this
one and we calmed it down cuz it seemed
a little weird I was like 10
psychological hacks and tricking people
into like anymore something and I was
like a little weird yeah I like that one
it's better weird I like yeah I'm like
so so hyper aware of like when people
are tried tricking like oh you trying to
trick me
yeah a lot of guys pretending to be your
friend but they want a book yeah you're
like hmm some girls just assume it girl
girls never I didn't have a lot of
girlfriends so like why is that
how come it's hard for girls to make
friends I think you want my personal
theory yeah you didn't have sisters it's
harder to make girlfriends yes exactly
so women are like a [ __ ] ticking time
bomb it's like a minefield you don't
know what the [ __ ] to say or do so true
can I tell you though in my 30s I've
made way more women friends because I
think our topics are finally aligned
like before was always celebrity culture
and like who's dating who and let's go
to a club and I don't want my boobs to
be like this or whatever and now it's
more like Oh where'd you get that home
décor
okay oh you want to go to the flea
market oh yeah I got plans
thank you points out the other day that
all girl conversations are just like
where'd you get that oh I got it here
yeah you should go here oh yeah that's a
great place have you been here so before
it was stuff official conversation yeah
those are those are the like how's the
sports team doing this yeah yeah but so
I used to be about all you got I used to
have more guy friends cuz I was into
football and comedy and like heavily
male-dominated topics but now now it's
like oh I
the girl topics were Oh where'd you get
this like purse I don't care about
purses at all yeah but now it's like
where'd you get those plants I'm like I
love plants I could talk about that more
[ __ ] plant I think this says tell me
about it would ya I'm like going the
other day it's Sunday
I'm watching my Colts game and Nicky
comes home from the flea market and
she's got another [ __ ] Papa doula
treat the deal first of all that was a
fiddly victory and second a second of
all I'm just sick of looking at [ __ ]
my whole place is filled to the freakin
looking at plaque class just chill pants
I got the rainforest cafe of my house
now
lucky but not in your office sniffing I
don't have the rain storm I want the
rain storm to clean air man yeah look at
your story I'm like did you guys boot
the Nicaragua let's no light in his bad
nose me no oh I'm so sick of the plans
they know you mean thank you really
nothing healthy about you so I get what
you and I can complain about anything so
chances are if you name something in my
life I will complain thank you back to
the so the first one was emphasize your
similarities so we all know that right
there do anything no you got there I
could do that try that on somebody
no actually I'm doing chemo number two
make friends with their friends no as
soon as I go around them in circle their
entire life take it over this
West type subside I get it I get it a
different perspective it does look kind
of creepy
I get it done but isn't that like
cyclical though cuz if you're trying to
make friends with their friends you
would have to use this list to make that
friends kind of counter to what the hell
can a friends with you cos happy for the
other thing it's like it's like if you
go to a party right some people just
stick to that one person that they only
know and then they don't venture out
like there's like if you make friends
with their friends they're like oh
they're getting a lot cool we can all go
[ __ ] do something together it's like
I said playlist we're just like a like
big it's almost like we're like we're
like all rowdy and we're all like
linking arms with each other and walk
and moving around in the water I hate
when I was younger like you have to go
to like these social things and the only
way I was like I gotta care enough to
[ __ ] talk these people are gonna
smash drunk because I've done that I
literally don't give a [ __ ] about any of
you dude I didn't have any social things
when I was younger I'm doing them now oh
okay well yeah what do you mean like not
like a party's because you know you go
to these bucket poor like could we cut
the college parties right so you go with
a couple of your friends or something
like that and then you have to try to
like be cool with everybody else so you
go talk to some of the girls that
they're kicking it with oh man you're
doing it all wrong dude so you know I
don't drink right but this is how I had
a lot of fun I get people [ __ ] up and
I [ __ ] with them oh that's fun dangerous
we just do married people game night now
yes that's our socializing what haven't
we invited you many times do they invite
you and you're like oh I'm sick like a
jack
you know control Jess and Joe painting
that way quite a few times it's like at
least four times well you know we had to
get some like why she texts you guys for
the Huntington whole sitting you know it
that was you
yeah that was your idea number three
reveal your applause so a
self-deprecating humor got it
yeah kind of like not like deep intimate
kind of like whoa things I do that too
much when you first meet someone it's
like God um I used to do that on dates
though just to filter people out because
I don't like superficial conversation so
I'm just like what's your biggest regret
in your whole life go first question
before the appetizers like drinks just
came okay go
what would you say well as I said this
date broke the [ __ ] backboard like
listen it wasn't about what they
answered it was about how they reacted
to the question can dis muhfucka take a
joke yeah like can can he answer it and
I not be like all like whoa or you know
yeah is he taking it too serious yeah
you know so interesting about like lists
like this that I really enjoy is that
even to do this list to make a friend
you still have to be socially competent
and understand how to do this list oh
that's true but some people they just
take everything for Batum and they don't
do it within like human social comments
so they couldn't be like this which was
this one it was reveal your fuzzy some
social say like you know you shouldn't
go venting your deepest insecurities
yeah but I'm saying like for socially
awkward people it's gonna be hard to do
this list cuz you have to ease into that
too you don't go like hi I'm Joe and
guess what dude I [ __ ] wanted to [ __ ]
my stepsister
that's what people who are too literal
do and that's what that's what you're
talking about yeah yeah like we're it's
like or though like come up to you in
bed yo look at this [ __ ] gash on my
wrist is that crazy and feel like I get
out of my face
I even the whole makeup friends with
their other friends like if you're
trying to make friends they'll probably
do it so much they'll completely ignore
the person to try to be IO do that with
people I have crushes on how does that
work up for you
well none with him yeah no well for all
of his friends and never talk to them
like I'm on a sitcom with that line
number four mirror then I'm gonna be
like oh [ __ ] out of my face you know
like mirror me kind of like freaks me
out I'm like stop like stop it I do it
to you when you say if you talk about
whatever we want it happens so
consciously if you're hanging out with
someone and you start going like this
and then the other person does that
or you lean forward and they lean
forward oh you know what I like I picked
up your habit farter Gio pointed out
that I picked up your habit cuz you
always go like like oh like that or
something like I started doing that I
don't know why yeah and you also start
speaking like a Vietnamese fall yeah
that's [ __ ] contagious
small is I started doing that even like
just randomly like not even on camera do
it in my head well in my head it's so
weird like you're him say like oh I
thought we gonna be talking about our
future this shit's gonna be used against
me in some way like take it out of
context no white girl races against a
white girl who spots an Asian for four
years is racist against Asian
she absorbed his culture through all
that like like friction like she's got
like Asian on her body inside of her
hey you could fetish size me all you
want I love to be fantasize I think guys
like it feel beautiful number five on
this list initiate physical contact Oh
No
so it's I don't like physical contact
friend you give him a friendly I don't
like when people do that cuz then I okay
so like you let's say you're a friend
and you do that like you're talking to
girls always grab this elbow and then I
don't know if I'm supposed to grab back
or not and I always get so confused yeah
they're like like oh you know it's so
billon like thank you and I try to like
do it back and I feel so weird and I
don't like it and want to do you know
hoodoos like this you guys know Dante
Bosco yeah I love him the whole time
that you're talking to this guy he's
like I don't mind either cuz he's cool
yeah it's just funny cuz you're the
whole time yeah you're the whole time
it's more a lot of Filipino guys are
touchy touchy
mm-hmm yeah I think it's more when girls
do it because I don't know how to be
friends with girls so I'm like is this
what we're supposed to do I don't know
he looks like a 40 year old man but he
has a 10 year olds voice like it's so
young his voice is so youthful he played
like a team
exactly recently in his 40s oh really oh
yeah he got you cold
yeah yeah that's cool all right all of
you guys want to see the rest of this
list check out the link in the
description I would say to simplify
though you just have to practice
practice practice and feel the energy
read the room cuz it's different for
each group it's not gonna be that
mirroring thing could work the best
like mirroring the in energy yet
mirroring the energy yeah add so so
don't be up here when everyone's chill
and introverted and being always lean
away from being literal in almost every
context just stay away from the idea
that being
a lot of these things I would take it
10% out of time
[Music]
[Music]